Okay,
so this is what we did last time.
We looked at a game involving an entrance and an incumbent in a market,
and the entrance had to decide whether to enter that market or not.
And if they stayed out the incumbent remainder monopolies and the monopolists
made 3 million in profit.
All right?
And if the entrant goes in it,
than the incumbent can decide whether to accommodate the entrance and just
settled for duopoly profits making a million each or the incumbent can fights,
in which case the incumbents makes no money at all and the entrance loses $1
million.
And we pointed out to a number of things about this game.
One was that when we analyzed it in a matrix fob,
we've quickly found that there were two nash equilibria that Nash Equilibria
what in and not fights and out and fights.
But we argued that backward induction tells us that the sensible answer is in
and not fight.
Once the incumbent knows the entrance is in,
they're not going to fight because one is bigger than zero.
And then an entrant anticipating this will enter.
And we talked a little bit more.
We said this other equilibrium,
this out fights equilibrium.
It is an equally rim because if the entrance believes the incumbents going to
fights,
then the entrance is going to stay at house and it's costless for the incumbent
to quote fights if they,
if in fact the entrant does the out because they never get called upon to fight
anyway.
So yeah.